so the wall street journal got a hold of
a bunch of internal documents from
facebook from the company's internal
racial justice chat room of course they
have one of those
and they found among many other things
that facebook employees are obsessed
with the site breitbart they hate
breitbart breitbart shouldn't be allowed
to talk why is breitbart on facebook
and so apparently
facebook cut traffic to breitbart news
by as much as a fifth without telling
them and they also do this to a bunch of
other conservative sites alex marlow
runs breitbart he joins us tonight to
respond to what we've just learned alex
thanks so much for coming on so were you
surprised by i mean i was a little
shocked by how open they were were you
surprised
yeah i was stop i was shocked only by
the framing of it the wall street
journal put out the story as if it was
going to be some sort of damnation hit
piece on breitbart and it contained a
smoking gun in it which is that these
woke sjws had pressured facebook senior
management to diminishing not just
breitbart traffic but traffic across
conservative media and deliberately
cutting down their most engaged users to
favorite to favorite corporate
billionaire-backed
multinational conglomerates to promote
their news over breitbart's which is
accurate which is incredibly popular and
it was thriving about dominating on the
platform
it's just so interesting i mean they
have all these different left-wing news
outlets which almost all of them and yet
they were completely fixated on the idea
that breitbart might have a story on
facebook they couldn't get over it like
no diversity of opinion did you note
this
absolutely tucker there's literally
there's literally billions of facebook
pages and this one page for whatever
reason triggers the left at such an
unbelievable degree that they have to
whine to their bosses to try to get us
censored thankfully it hasn't totally
worked yet but every republican member
of congress should take note of this
this came before the 2020 election
tucker all their criticism of us were
before 2020 these change votes and
change minds right well that's it they
hate facebook because they think that
trump voters organized on facebook
that's why they're trying to
force facebook to censor because we have
an election coming up obviously um you
know that anyway alex marlow i
appreciate your coming on tonight thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else